les soixante années 90 aujourd'hui
dur à dire le musée de la ville vous
invite dans un monde où les époques se
mélangent le vintage c'est sont tous les
objets qui datent des années 50 aux
années 90 environ qui sont des objets
authentiques souvent de marques qui ont
marqué leur époque et qui sont ressortis
aujourd'hui réutilisés pour être mélangé
à des objets contemporains
on ne fait pas une histoire de la mode
on explore la façon dont certains objets
sont ressortis des placards
pourquoi ce sont ces objets là et pas
d'autres et comment aider le visiteur à
distinguer sur une brocante par exemple
quel sera l'objet vraiment vintage
originale et une copie ou une
contrefaçon
des objets issus des collections du
musée ou de prêts d'habitants du
territoire du mobilier mais aussi de la
mode des pièces rares et anciennes à
découvrir comme lors d'un défilé
c'était un choix justement parce que ce
sont les top models qui ont diffusé
d'abord le vintage dans la mode et ils
sont au scénographe qui ont voulu jouer
sur un module de seynod que vous
retrouvez un peu partout qui est la
table lac
ikea ils ont voulu faire la
confrontation entre les pièces iconiques
vintage et cet objet qui est vraiment le
type de la société de consommation qu'on
retrouve partout qu'on jette qu'on
rachète pour quelques euros du channel
du courrèges des kickers des pièces de
qualité qu'on trouve encore aujourd'hui
dans nos armoires et vous quel style
êtes vous